what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk all things marvel
and everything relating to the marvel
cinematic universe and things are just
not stopping with all of the new news
about spider-man 3.
and absolutely nobody is complaining tom
holland is officially in atlanta for
filming on spider-man 3. if you're new
be sure to subscribe so you don't miss
out on
any of the latest spider-man 3 news and
leaked photos and videos and also so you
can enter for a chance to win this
week's spider-man
imposter funko pop so these leaked
photos are coming from an instagram
account
fabian r.i chad who apparently is
somehow
on the set for spider-man 3 and in
another photo that he posted
it also says that he's going to be on
the loki set as well but let's take a
look at this first leaked photo and the
caption that he has posted on his story
it says new spider-man on the way and we
see a
huge experiment type chair going on here
now the first thing that comes to my
mind since the caption of this says new
spider-man
on the way is ben reilly aka
the scarlet spider now the reason i
think this is twofold one is because of
the caption it simply says new
spider-man on the way
and the picture clearly shows that this
spider-man is going to be
created and the scarlet spider ben
reilly is a created
spider-man ben reilly is created and
grown in a lab
by the jackal and he's actually a clone
of spider-man peter parker
now he's raised with the task of
eventually fighting and taking on and
defeating spider-man but he would end up
becoming his ally
and at one point in time they would even
refer to each other as
brothers now at one point in time in the
comics peter parker would leave and ben
reilly would become
the spider-man he would take on that
mantle for a little bit so he's a pretty
big deal
and if this is in fact true if this is
another ben reilly then that's just
adding to
the spider-verse no technically this
character is not coming from a different
universe
but it is another spider-man in our
universe now of course there are other
options for what we are seeing in this
photo
there is the possibility that this
person just assumes that this creation
is for a new spider-man
however if there was no caption to this
i would definitely say that this
looks like oscorp if you notice all the
cans and containers for gas in the
background
they surely do look like something that
would contain some type of
serum a serum that could be some type of
super soldier serum or a certain serum
that could turn
a certain norman osborne into the green
goblin
now remember in spider-man far from home
somebody bought the avengers tower and
they're reconstructing it now of course
the biggest guesses right now are that
it's going to be
either the oscorp tower or the fantastic
four's baxter building well if we
consider the connection that it had and
far from home
and the possibility that the fantastic
four might not enter the mcu for at
least a couple of years
it could be a relatively safe assumption
to assume that this tower is now
the ozcorp tower and this could be some
type of oscorp
experiment now of course if this is the
ozcorp building it ties into everything
perfectly
and could do exactly what we wanted to
do set up the sinister
six now there were some reports before
spider-man fire from home came out
stating that the sinister six were
indeed going to get set up in a
post-credits scene for far from home but
of course that didn't happen
however there is always the possibility
that marvel simply saved that for the
next film so not only could we get some
type of spider-verse and spider-man 3
but perhaps the sinister six could be in
the film or be set up for a future film
as well
now of course this may not be oscorp or
ben reilly this could be something
completely different as some people on
my instagram pointed out
there are two panels on the sides of
this chair that do kind of look like
brain washing panels
very similar to what has been used on
bucky and although this would make sense
for a ben riley since he's designed to
kill spider-man
it could be used on any different number
of characters but right now my bet is on
this is going to be ben riley or some
type of
oscorp experiment perhaps leading us to
seeing norman osborne
become the green goblin in the marvel
cinematic universe but let me know your
thoughts about this
what do you think this is and what do
you think is happening
in this photo please let me know what
you think is going on in the comments
down below
again don't forget to subscribe so you
can stay up to date on all of the latest
leaks videos photos everything for
spider-man 3.
don't forget to give the video a like
and for live updates you can follow me
on instagram and twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching
woof
you